i think one of the things that you can
say about me is i never when i was broke
i didn't let my my bank account define
me and right when i'm not broke i'm not
gonna let my bank account to find me i
am you know i'll try to be my own person
and just my friends are my friends
that never changed my pittsburgh friends
are still my my great friends you know
my college friends my rugby friends all
the different segments of my life
they're still my guys
[Music]
what's going on what up tv not a thing
how you doing good man thanks for having
me man i appreciate you my pleasure
appreciate you coming through
absolutely um so to start it off uh tell
us who you are
oh my goodness um grew up in pittsburgh
pennsylvania um born in squirrel hill
moved to the south hills birdland um and
then mount lebanon and um
my dad did upholstery on cars my mom did
odd jobs
just just a normal kid man that just
happened to be have an aptitude for
business from as long as i can remember
was was it one of your dreams like as a
kid like i know i was in the backyard
man my brother
was trying to be michael jordan and
scottie pippen uh i was mj of course but
uh like was it a dream of yours to own
an nba team no hell no
yeah
honestly it wasn't until i tried to buy
the mavs that even crossed my mind
really like yeah when i was a kid you
know i played sports not very well but
yeah i wanted to be earl of pearl monroe
i had to skip moving everything and a
baseball with salem state university by
the way
exactly
i never really thought that i would ever
be in a position to own anything man i
just wanted to have a good life and try
to find my way to college so now
you know all these things that you've
done in life all this stuff that's been
a part of your journey tell us a little
bit about what that was like like what
it was like growing up and um in
pittsburgh you know my mom was really
young when she had me she was 20 and so
you know in hindsight i realized how
little my parents really knew right
because they were just young
but my dad would just get up and go to
work and he was he neither one of them
went to college and they were like you
guys i have two younger brothers brian
and jeff like you guys are going to
college and we're going to figure it out
because education is important
and you've got to find your own path and
he was always pushing me and both my
parents were pushing me to to be
independent
and
however it started i don't know from the
time i was nine ten years old i was
hustling i was i was one of those kids
that was always selling something yeah
yeah like i was selling baseball cards
right i would go buy baseball cards and
then i'd flip them right get as many you
know get good and flip and package it
then i'd go down to the park where we
would pick up play pickup or whatever
there would be this bench that was there
and i would just sit there and repackage
baseball cards and i'd say okay there's
definitely one pittsburgh pirate in one
of these right you might get roberto
clemente you might get willie stargeon
and i'd mark him up and make some money
and you know and that's how i'd get
spending money and i remember one day my
dad was playing poker
i was like dad i need a new pair of
converse right and he's like i see those
you know those shoes on your feet they
still work right and i'm like yeah he's
like well when you have a job you can
buy whatever you want but until then
those shoes still work and i'm like dad
i can't get a job i'm 12 years old and
one of his poker buddies speaks up and
goes yeah i got a job for you i'm like
what he goes i've got these boxes of
garbage bags and you can go sell them
around the neighborhood and i'm like
cool like boxes and boxes
right so literally i would go to our
neighbors and i go hi i'm your neighbor
mark do you use garbage bags you sound
like a shark tank yeah right yeah
exactly and of course everybody uses
garbage bags so never forget they cost
me three bucks for a box of a hundred i
would sell them for six bucks and i
would just take them to them every
couple weeks right whenever they needed
more garbage bags and i'm making 20
bucks a week which was like
big time i got my shoes and you know but
that taught me to be confident and that
taught me that i could sell and that
taught me that selling was helping not
convincing you know because once i
figured out that everybody needed
garbage bags then it really became
obvious to me that if i can find things
that people needed right and wanted and
i could do it a better way than what
they were doing it then i could make
some money and that's kind of stayed
with me i was just about to say it's
crazy how you was thinking about that at
12 and everything you just said
basically translates to everything
you're basically doing now in life yeah
exactly i mean because that's what it's
all about i mean you know selling isn't
convincing somebody to do something they
don't want to do selling is
understanding what chris paul needs and
then finding a way to provide it in a
better way than what they're doing now
you make it sound way too easy but it's
not as hard as it sounds right but most
you know it's like basketball right
there's a lot of guys that maybe we're
more talented than you right right one
thing i know and respect about you and
the few times we've talked like you talk
about you know doing the work right
getting on synergy sports which i was
excited about because there's a company
i had helped get going right and
invested them and always watching the
place knowing the other teams plays you
know when they call them out so you know
what's going to happen being able to
guide business is the exact same way
most people don't put in the work
business is the exact same way you know
i have all these corny sayings practice
too you can't get it wrong how you do
anything is how you do everything yeah
yeah
i just still to this day try to remind
myself of these things all the time for
you you started college in pittsburgh
yeah and then went to indiana yeah why
when i was 16 i decided i wanted to take
college classes at night just to see if
i was as smart as i thought i was
and so so at 16 you were what uh junior
junior yeah in high school yeah and you
just started taking college yeah so i
just said what the hell right i'll just
take these classes and i took a
psychology class and did good in it and
then i wanted to um
take a business class at my high school
mount lebanon high school and they
wouldn't let me do that
and so i'm like
well then i'm just going to go to
college right so i dropped out of high
school didn't go back for my senior year
and went to the university of pittsburgh
but they didn't have a real business
school back then i decided i wanted to
go to business school saw a list of the
top 10 undergraduate business schools
and indiana was the cheapest and got in
and had never seen the campus didn't
visit none of that stuff just went sight
unseen and turned out okay
you graduated from indiana what was your
dream job
well i was i wanted to start my own
company at some level right so all
through indiana i had all kinds of side
hustles because i pretty much had to pay
for my own college and so whether it was
party promoting my freshman and
sophomore years
to um having a chain letter to pay for
my junior year
to um
opening up a bar that was like the hot
spot on campus my senior year until we
got busted for letting all my friends in
because
i i just turned 21 you know so i was a
hustler a bunch of my buddies had come
down to dallas
and they were like you got to come down
is that what got you to texas yeah yeah
a bunch of my buddies were down here and
they're like look the weather's good the
economy's really starting to hop um and
the women are hot i'm like i didn't hear
the first two i'm like i'm coming boom
right i'm on my way on my way three
bedroom apartments five other roommates
so six of us live in a three-bedroom
apartment i was in last so i was the guy
who didn't have his own room didn't have
his own closet on the floor
couch right or some you know buddies
were out i'm taking their bed so that's
where i got started in dallas and i got
a job working as a bartender at night
and then finally got a job um
in the computer industry and that's
really where i realized okay i really
like these computers i mean i have an
aptitude for it and this this is it i'm
going for it so when i say broadcast.com
is that menu
[Laughter]
right yeah i don't think people realize
what it was all about though um because
it's been so long now i sold my first
company micro solutions in 1989 um 1990
i guess when it closed and retired just
took time off party like a rock star
and would get together with one of my
indiana buddies todd wagner and one day
he's sitting down it's you know late
1994 early 95 and he's like look this
new internet thing there's got to be a
way that we can use it to listen to
indiana basketball because we're in
dallas and you know this is before
you could get it with directv or cable
or whatever right and i'm like okay let
me see if i can figure it out because my
first company i would write software
taught myself the right software did
networking wider so it was a perfect fit
to figure it out so i bought a packer
bell computer put into the second
bedroom my house connected a radio to it
and we just started working with
different software didn't write all the
software but wrote enough to get it up
and running
next thing you know we started this
website called audionet worked with the
local radio station kliff i set up
an a vcr an old school vcr next to their
radio station i would record it take the
vcr tapes encode it put it on a server
in the second bedroom my house and then
just email and go online and tell as
many people look if you want to listen
to dallas sports and stuff come to the
site called audionet.com blew up
immediately three years later it turned
into broadcast.com we added video we
went public it was the biggest first day
ip on the history of the stock market at
the time and we were youtube i mean
literally
hundreds of internet radio stations
hundreds of radio stations tv stations
you know streaming like we went and got
the rights to um north carolina
basketball and we were showing online
michael jordan mixtapes once you get
that it's a wrap yeah right so we would
just we just blew up and then yahoo came
along and bought us and paid us um
i think was 5.7 billion dollars in stock
not in cash so then i had to protect my
the stock that i got because you know
fortunately i did i did this thing
called hedging and it protected me when
the whole internet bubble burst and
that allowed me to turn it into cash and
then a couple weeks later i was trying
to buy the mavs yeah so on to that onto
that so all of the stuff that you were
doing in technology computers and
everything like that
why the mavericks well i was season
ticket holder right but i had been going
to mavs games since i got to dallas um
but in the 90s they were really bad and
literally you could buy a ticket
upstairs and just walk down and sit in
the front row right because there was
nobody there and even though we were
awful it was the start of the 99 2000
season i was there with my girlfriend
now wife
and
the place wasn't sold out you know and
so you're a season ticket holder 99 2000
yeah right and where are your seats at
my seats are right by the mavs bench
where you sit
close closer yeah a little bit yeah two
rows back
i was into it right and then there was
nobody there and i remember tuning in
yeah there was nobody there right nobody
it was opening night and the place
wasn't sold out and this was in the old
reunion arena and i'm like i can do a
better job than this right then it hit
me ding ding ding now i can afford this
stuff right right right you know so
my my i talked to my ticket rep um a guy
named mark who then connected me to mark
mcguire and mark aguirre was working for
ross perot jr who was the owner then and
he connected me together and the season
started like beginning november end of
october by january 4th um so only six
weeks later give or take
i owned the mavs
what yeah no no no no talent you rewind
you don't just sit at the game and then
six weeks later pretty much on the yeah
i like that and what's what's crazy for
me is around then i was 16 years old 16
17 years old and i'm a high school
basketball player and i
i'm telling you man like my senior high
school even like when i was a freshman
at wake like i loved everything dirk yo
yeah everything jerk was the bad yeah i
used to like turn my feet in on my free
throws you remember when dirk used to
shoot free throws like this yeah a
little knock knock yeah yeah yeah i used
to do that for a little while what not
just so i could shoot like dirk and i
tell you even to sit here and have this
conversation is so crazy because i
i remember when you bought the team
and i saw you like this
right seriously i think at some point we
all thought that someone buying a team
or something had to have a suit on and
all this different type stuff and to see
you today the same way you were then i
think says a lot you've always genuinely
been a fan of not just your team but the
game and that's that's dope to see man
yeah i mean because it's it's for all of
us right yeah and i always say i don't
own the team i just handle the finances
but all mavs fans everywhere own the
team that's what makes basketball or all
sports right so much different than
traditional businesses look at apple
right
multi-trillion dollar market cap no
one's throwing a parade in cupertino
when they have you know a super quarter
right right right right there's not a
whole city that gets on fire right when
you're moving like when you guys you
know with the suns last year just coming
out of nowhere and bam getting into the
finals the whole city is on fire that's
a great point yeah
shark tank yeah
what was the pitch to you that got you
involved in shark tank um
it was like we're doing this this
business show right do you want to come
on as a guest
and i'd watch the show and i'm like okay
you know it was on abc
and it was bouncing around right it
wasn't on any one night and i'm thinking
all right i'm gonna go on and i'm just
gonna blow them up right because they're
not gonna see me coming and this is a
business show and it's okay right but i
don't think it's gonna last so i'm just
gonna this is you know prime time
network tv and i'm just going to mess
with everybody so i get on there and
just tear them all up they had no idea
what was coming but all of a sudden you
know like it did in other countries
shark tank starts to take off and
you know what it from what it started as
me just having fun to what it's become
which is a way to educate families kids
about businesses and really get kids
excited about entrepreneurship
that's what got me really to stay with
the show we'll be locked in yeah we'll
be locked it's the coolest thing because
like you said it's not just
for adults right like my whole family my
parents my wife my kids will be sitting
there watching you know and there are
products that we
buy now all the time that came from as
long as you're mine
right right so but for you but for you
you heard hundreds of pitches like maybe
thousands of pitches thousands of
pitches in
trying to figure out all these different
deals and whatnot what would be your
biggest advice to a entrepreneur or
somebody trying to start a business well
you know first know your business right
i think people will always stop and say
well i want to start a business what
should i do and if you don't know you're
not ready right you know
you've got to
have something that you're good at and
if you're going to be if you're going to
do it you got to be the best at it
because i'll tell them look if i come in
and compete with you i'm going to kick
your ass are you ready to compete with
me yeah right and you've got to work
like there's someone working 24 hours a
day to take it away from you you have a
website that lists all your different
businesses yes mark cuban.com right
right yeah all all your different
businesses and all because do you have
like a separate company that's just for
like shark tape no right no no they're
all i mean so i don't have like a fund
that i that invests in all the different
companies it's just me making direct
investments and all of yeah but this is
it's not just the money it's the time oh
yeah
yeah yeah there's a lot going on people
who help me yeah it takes some people a
lot smarter than me to make all this
work right i've got a lot of really
really great people that are um around
that make me look smart so when it comes
to crypto and blockchain and stuff how
do you feel about that i think it's a
big part of the future right i really
really do but i think people are looking
at the wrong way
people get really amped up about um the
price of the the currency the
cryptocurrencies right the tokens and
they think that's really what crypto is
but it's not that's the noise right the
signal is if i were going to start a
business how can i use this new
technology to give myself a competitive
advantage and disrupt an industry and so
you know to give you an example
is nfts right everybody's all amped
about nfts and you see guys with their
board ape yacht club all day long all
day long
and it's a collectible just like
anything else but to me nfts are just a
proof of concept and an example of how
smart contracts work when you go through
the process of creating an nft one of
the things they always ask you is what's
your royalty rate
and so when i set one up for the first
time i'm like royalties right how the
hell does that work because there's no
other way to make money every time a
digital asset is resold and get paid a
royalty and then i'm thinking okay well
if it works for these nfts where else
can i use this stuff right what other
business applications can i use right
the nfts were just showing you another
way to do other things proof of concept
right proof of concept again it's like
basketball right basketball right now is
changing and technology keeps on
changing yeah right it went from you
know post up and all this different
types of the game changes it changed it
because the technology made people
smarter right you went from synergy
right to second spectrum yeah right yeah
and then the data's different and now
we're getting into using computer vision
and ai for pose estimation all this is
just technology changing that comes back
to biomechanics yeah all the
biomechanics but how do you track the
biomechanics right right one of your
recent hires in the past couple years
with cynthia yeah said marshall yeah
yeah
marshall yeah she's a machine i mean
she's she's a force of nature she's
she's in she's amazing you know we had
some challenges um that we went through
three years ago and you know i i hadn't
been connected to the business side of
it i was always on the basketball side
and some things went wrong and i had to
own up to him
i needed somebody who could come in that
understood how to turn the culture of an
organization around
and she has just been a superstar she
don't play either no she don't play yeah
yeah she says that all the time i don't
play yeah i don't play i don't play but
that's who she is and she changed the
culture she changed the organization you
know diversity inclusion is is a tough
topic
you know because a lot of people look at
it just being about a checklist
and what i've learned particularly from
her is
that it's not about checking the boxes
it's about being pragmatic and doing
business the right way because what i
learned from her is when when we bring
people from different communities that
opens doors into those communities
right and so like dallas has the sixth
largest indian population in the country
i didn't know that did not know that you
just said so you want to find people
from that community to sell into that
community you want to find people of
color who can connect because
i can walk in there and people who look
like me can walk in there yeah
i'm not going to have the same effect or
have the same understanding
and she
she already knew that right she knew how
to not only understand it not only
recognize the impact but how to deliver
it and that's what makes her special and
she's just got that energy and that vibe
and that love that comes out of her
genuine yeah unbelievably genuine so
i've known you for a while mark and i
didn't even know that you you had had
kids until i seen you on tick-tock
i've seen you on tick-tock
see you on tick-tock with your daughter
man to tell you the truth cause i i've
done a few of my kids you know what i
mean and i'm telling you man i didn't
see you
win championships i hadn't seen you win
big games but
i don't ever think i've seen you as
happy as you are when you're on those
videos with your kids i can get them to
do them every day twice a day i would do
them i don't care how embarrassed i get
by them yeah it's fun right because i
mean you know now they're the joy of my
life they're everything and
you know it took me a while to realize
that because like when they're really
really little you don't really
appreciate it yeah but once they became
real people you know there's it's just
yeah there's just nothing better and if
if i had a choice between just spending
time with them it's like i tell people
the most precious word in the dictionary
for me is dad yeah when you hear your
kids call you dad yeah
there's only one way there's only three
people in the universe who can say that
to me and those are most important
all that we talked about you could see
you was into it but when i brought up
your kids yeah
jumped out your seat and it's scary too
right because you know
you had you had to work your way up and
you know and it's your success in a lot
of respects but then it just terrifies
you you know because your kids can't
copy that same path right you know as
much as you know your path and i know my
path and it's not going to be my kid's
path they've got to find their own and
it scares me because i don't want them
to grow up to be entitled right you know
i don't want them to take everything for
granted i want them to feel something
that you have to work for to get it yeah
and it's you know but they ain't dumb
they ain't down no they
they know exactly you know who paid for
the house and how you know that's the
challenge i think that a lot of us face
man and i'm just
uh grateful to sit down and talk to you
all these years man we never talking
this long man so mark thank you so much
appreciate you yes
[Music]
you